est-ce que ça vaut le coup pour Noël que votre livre a
été vendu et qu'ils ont donné du papier de peau de léopard
pour emballer le livre dedans c'est vrai que
vous en savez beaucoup, n'êtes-vous pas
parlé aux États-Unis en tant que
sœur de John Colleen ou est-elle
parlée comme  La sœur collègue de Jackie
[Music]
ce n'est jamais mentionné en Amérique ouais mais
en Europe c'est un peu plus
parce qu'en Europe elle a été une grande star
pendant tant d'années ouais mais en Amérique
parce que j'ai eu tellement de
livres à succès là-bas qui ont  été
numéro un que les gens ne connaissent pas
vraiment savent qu'ils n'y pensent pas
non jamais tu es la réponse du
best-seller géant dans le monde entier combien d'exemplaires as-
tu vendu jusqu'à présent environ 100 milliards de
livres que tu écris chaque jour oui tu
dois  en tant qu'écrivain tu le sais mais tu
dois te traîner jusqu'au bureau
parce que sinon tu ne le fais pas beaucoup
de gens en parlent ils veulent le
faire ils disent oh j'écrirai un livre un jour
ouais ils ne le font jamais  il vous avez dû
demander par bien oui
absolu  combien d'heures vous roulez chaque
jour en fait je suppose que je commence à courir
vers neuf heures du matin ouais
et je roule jusqu'à environ six ou
sept et si je suis vraiment sur une lancée
j'écrirai toute la nuit et je  je vais mettre une bouteille de
scotch sur le bureau et écrire
j'aime beaucoup combien de pages dix dix
j'essaie ce qui est un autre âge ouais ouais 10 c'est
assez bon 20 c'est super et on n'est pas
bon quel conseil me donneriez-vous  pour
écrire un best-seller, je pense que vous l'avez déjà
fait,
mais si je devais donner des conseils aux
gens, je vous dirais que vous
ne pouvez pas en parler, vous devez le faire,
vous devez mettre ce cul sur
cette chaise et en fait  faites-le vous savez
parlez-moi de Rockstar votre dernier livre
bien quelle star est un livre que je
voulais écrire parce que c'est une histoire passionnante
que je l'ai vue comme une histoire passionnante sur
trois rock stars Bobby mondella qui est
la superstar de l'âme noire Rafaela qui est
si belle  fille et elle devient
célèbre au Brésil, elle chante le
Funk Rock brésilien  et Chris Phoenix qui est la
rock star anglaise, il est comme ce qui est Joe
Watts Mick Jagger ouais les gens le
comparent à ça parce qu'il est une
rock star anglaise définitive, je veux dire qu'il
commence à 18 ans et monte à 36, je veux dire que
son âge change dans le livre et vous  le
voir passer par tout c'est presque un
manuel de comment devenir une rock star tu as
rencontré beaucoup de rock stars tu sais tu as rencontré
les Beatles les pierres oui je suis au
centre commercial ouais
j'en ai rencontré beaucoup parce que mon mari a
toujours sur Discord  taxe alors oui tu portes
les ad-libs le célèbre malheureusement à Londres
c'est là que j'ai rencontré mon mari les Royals j'ai
rencontré tous les Beatles et les pierres ouais
et le trajet et tout le monde et c'était
super pour moi parce qu'au fil des années j'ai
regardé  vous savez comment les rock
stars ont changé dans leur carrière,
les femmes de leur vie et si un film
devait être fait à partir d'une rock star, lequel
aimeriez-vous que j'aimerais voir piquer
pour le rockeur anglais torride parce
qu'il a une rock star  yeux tu sais qu'il a
tha  t genre de sentiment charismatique quand
il se met devant la caméra et peut-être
Whitney Houston pour la fille j'ai vu
Whitney à New York combien d'argent a été
investi aux États-Unis pour le lancement
de votre livre je n'en ai aucune idée je n'ai jamais
demandé ça mais  Je m'assure juste que
non je ne pose pas cette question mais je
m'assure qu'ils le font correctement qu'ils
mettent beaucoup de choses là-dessus c'est très bien fait
il y a une publicité dans laquelle vous dites
quand il s'agit de la vie des riches
et des  célèbre j'ai écrit le livre c'est
vrai c'est vrai eh bien je l'ai fait et je pense que
vous savez quand les gens lisent mon genre de
fiction, ils
regardent de très près ce qui se passe réellement
parce que si je disais la vraie vérité personne
ne la quitterait  nous devons découvrir qui c'est à
chaque fois que vous faites un bond vous
êtes très
oui j'adore les léopards ouais je juste euh je
pense que ce sont de beaux animaux et
ils sont très puissants très fort
gimmick d'une certaine manière je suppose que c'est vrai
que  pour Noël ton livre a été vendu
et ce th  Ils ont donné du papier en peau de léopard pour
emballer le livre dedans c'est vrai que tu en sais
beaucoup tu n'en sais pas grand chose tu
as cette photo sauvage de moi
allongé sur un tapis en peau de léopard avec des
vêtements et ils l'ont enroulé autour du  réservez
comme un type spécial de promotion de Noël
c'est bon match sur Daisy c'était amusant
vous devez vous amuser dans la vie et ils
disent faites-en un Noël Jackie Collins
c'est vrai n'auriez-vous
pas préféré être impliqué dans  la littérature,
je veux dire au lieu d'un livre
commercial, mais vous voyez, je suis un conteur
ouais, je n'ai jamais prétendu être un
grand écrivain littéraire, je ne veux pas être
un écrivain littéraire et je
ne pourrais probablement pas être un écrivain littéraire, mais j'aime
pour raconter des histoires j'ai abandonné l'école
quand j'avais 15 ans et je savais que celle que je
voulais faire était la bonne et les hommes lisent mes
livres parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils sont très
torrides les femmes très sexy les lisent
parce qu'elles aiment les femmes fortes et mes
vrais fans  lisez-les parce qu'ils aiment
l'humour
ne voudriez-vous pas exc  Hange 1 million d'exemplaires
contre le prix Pulitzer non définitivement
que ferais-je avec le droit je veux dire que vous
ne souffrez pas d'avoir autant de succès et
d'écrire des romans commerciaux parce que
moi-même je ne les considère jamais comme commerciaux
je pense que quand je dis c'est ce que vous
veux écrire quand j'écris Rockstar je n'écris
pas Rockstar pour sortir et vendre des
millions d'exemplaires je suis prêt car
c'est ce que je veux faire et je suis très
content qu'il vende beaucoup d'unités d'exemplaires
mais ce n'est pas la raison  je le
fais tu ne veux pas écrire un jour un
livre sans recettes rien que sur toi ta
ta vie avec ton mari une biographie
un misérable tu serais si important ce
ne serait pas misérable tu serais très
heureuse ta soeur  a quitté l'Angleterre avant
toi et tu l'as rejointe oui à Los
Angeles
non elle était une star de cinéma à Hollywood
quand j'étais cet enfant sauvage en Angleterre
ouais et j'ai été renvoyé de l'école
parce que je faisais signe à Regents Park
il y avait un gars qui  utilisé pour
flash est que ce que y  ouais appelez ça en France
ouais et j'avais l'habitude de lui faire signe et j'avais l'
habitude de dire ah appelé au jour le jour donc ils
étaient vraiment croisés avec moi les profs
ils disaient qu'il fallait se débarrasser de cette fille
et je jouais vrai et tout le temps ça
était mauvais j'avais l'habitude d'aller dans le sud de la
France et de voler Henry Miller à
la pharmacie locale et de le
ramener clandestinement en Angleterre parce qu'à cette époque
c'était quatre millions ouais ouais
elle devient romancière maintenant ta
sœur maintenant je pense que tout le monde elle
vient  J'ai toujours perçu ma soeur comme
une actrice et dans la vie je pense que tu as
une vocation la mienne c'est d'écrire et la sienne c'est
de jouer mais elle crie sur ton
territoire non pas vraiment je pense qu'après 20
ans et 12 bouquins elle va devoir courir
très vite  en effet, il n'y a pas de bagarre
entre vous deux, nous sommes les
meilleurs amis du monde, vous avez toujours été la
presse aimerait qu'il en soit autrement,
mais nous l'avons toujours été, mais vous ne voulez pas
dire si souvent non, pas vous
ne se rencontrent pas souvent nous nous rencontrons à
airpo  rts bonjour je vais à Paris et
tu vas ailleurs tu es
mariée avec le même homme depuis
20 ans 21 ans ouais longtemps
longtemps c'est différent de ta soeur maintenant
très différent tu en penses quoi  une
vie à propos de
euh je n'y pense pas vraiment
j'écris juste sur les autres ouais tu
es inspiré par elle parfois non non non
tu veux le droit par exemple
eh bien c'est drôle tu sais j'ai écrit un livre
intitulé Hollywood maris et dedans je
avait cette superstar scandaleuse appelée
Silver Anderson et elle avait ce genre de
petit ami qui était comme une bombe et
Hustler et Peter Holm sont venus me voir lors d'
une fête un soir et il a dit oh Jackie
merci beaucoup de m'avoir fait paraître si
bien j'ai dit  Peter si c'était à propos de toi
ça aurait été un livre différent